i don't think we've talked about this
before but what are your thoughts on
this is philosophical free will versus
not having any free will
you're free in some regards and
determined in others the farther out you
look in the future the more your
behavior is free will like and
the closer it is to the present the more
your behavior is determined so for
example
if you make a ballistic movement so if i
move my hand rapidly from here to here
and stop it i disinhibit that movement
it's ballistic
i have no free will once i've initiated
the movement i can't react fast enough
to stop my hand i have to pre-plan that
using unconscious mechanisms beforehand
and then allow the program to run
as you move towards an action you become
increasingly determined
we treat each other as if we have free
will and societies that are predicated
on the assumption that we have free will
seem to be functional societies and when
we observe our own behavior we
treat ourselves like we have free will
and we reward and punish ourselves as if
we have free will
i'm not willing to dispense with that
presumption
given its high degree of functionality
even though it's not easy to understand
how it might be the case it may be that
we have free will because we're actually
too complex to be determined
simple systems act in a determinate
manner but once they exceed a certain
level of complexity i don't think that
that's the case anymore
i don't know how to understand that
though i like that that
you can kind of aim to where you're
going and then you have tons of options
right especially if you're looking at
career or
who you're going to marry maybe or
family or you know
big things career particularly so you
can
aim but then each action you take leads
to a limited number of actions or maybe
just
one realistically well it better because
otherwise you wouldn't be able to act
you actually want to constrain your
field of choices until you hit a
determined point because then you act
the obvious choice or or even the
inevitable choice
you